[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
おっ
a 誰もご紹介をいただきました山村賢寺です
まず
皆さんにお聞きたいのが風景写真は一体どのようにして取られている風に
思われますでしょうか
先に私が撮った写真を名前が一緒にご覧になって
みましょう
スペシャはいいのかな
いいですかっ
たのかな
視聴しましください
すいませんトラブルに見舞われているんですけれども
出来るのでしょうかねちなみにこれはのライブ配信をしているということで
今この問題も一緒になってライブ配信をしていると思われます
大丈夫でしょうか
はい大丈夫なようですまず1枚の女の写真がのサンフランシスコで撮ったものになり
ます
子さん10月からが一番ベストシーズンなんですけどえーと今も9月からもう始まって
おりまして私のをその友達とかもすでに撮り始めていろんなソーシャルメディアに写真
を投稿しているのがもうこちらですね
こちらが a
も実際夜長に山に登りましてその頂上に立って日の出前にこう写真を撮るというところ
なんですけれども
手前がどうきりになってますねキビの上にいますんでも雲海状態になっております
て多くの町並みがそのサンフランシスコの街になっており
次がユタ州で通った写真になります
こちらがあの子様て振って
州立公園というところでして1日限定20人しか入れないところで生活これがの
水たまりが玉置るんで
水鏡でこうリフレクションが起きてるんですけどもこれが見れるのが3月のある
一部期間だけというようなものです
良い一体あの風景写真っていうのはいったい何なんでしょうか
風景写真はその季節もしくはその時間にしか見れないものを煌1枚として切り取って
いるわけなんですね
そして年に1回もしか場合によってはもう数年に1回しかないチャンスっていうものを
取り入ってます
予定すべて
準備をしてそのチャンスをこうつかみにいってるっていうのが風景写真2
あります
もう少し高突っ込んで見てみましょう
こちらの写真は夜の写真です
そして何故かこうこの穴から光が出ているんですね
この写真はいったいどういう条件で取れるでしょうか
5つあります
まず1つは場所ですもちろん
あの洞窟から光が出てますねこの穴があるところじゃないとこれが見れません
その次が天気です
この日は晴れでしたもちろん雨でも曇りでもこれを見ることができません
て3つ目が満月です
実はこの光は満月の光なんですね
ちょうど満月が沈もうとしていてこの岩の裏の向こうにこう
隠れているな状況ですそこから満月の光がふわなっても出ているような状況です
西洋爪が
時間で時間帯になります私が撮影したのが午前4時です
ちょうど運の良い事につきが
沈む時間帯と対応がこう出る時間帯というのが同じ時間6時でした
太陽がもちろんを出てしまうともちろんスキーの光り方が弱いんであの光を見ることが
できません
もちろん月が沈んでしまったらばあの光は見ることができないんでちゃんとその時間帯
を見て取りに行っているわけなんです
そして最後の5番目が月の角度方角になります
こちらがチーズで上から真上から見たような状況です
真ん中にあるのが良いはでちょうどこの子みたいになっているところがそのイワナの
ところなんですね
この日は
左ななめ下に向かって青色の線があるんですけどもこれが
月が沈む各北郭の方が降ったんですね
このアナと月が沈む方角が一緒に重なり合わないとあの現象が見ることができないです
この5つの条件がそろって初めてこの写真が撮れるというものです
実際この現象が見れるのは年に1回もしくは2年に1回しか見れない状況です
大丈夫でしょうか
はい戻りましたん
そこで私は風景写真も
へ
まあプライベートも仕事もそのチャンスのつかみ方っていうのはもう全部一緒なんじゃ
ないのかなというふうに思っております
そこで本日は how to テイクチャンスどうやってそのチャンスをつかむのかに
ついてお話をさせていただきます
主に3つの
お題があります一つが目標を決めましょうということで
二つ目がもうところやれよと言う
最後はもうチャンスはどこからやってくるんですかというところについてお話をいたし
ます
じゃあまず目標を決めるということから
皆さん
この
一緒にちょっとしたその対応していきたいんですけれども
え
まず目をつぶってみてください
そして閉じたまま今私がちょっと見せていたんですけどねお酉様
まま
この会場内に一体どれだけの青色のものがあるのかをちょっと思い出してみてください
それが壁だったり光だったりもしくは近くに座っている方の洋服苦痛か番だったりし
ます
なんでもいいんだ思い出してみてください
では目を開けてみてください
今目を開けて多分
大体の方が青色のものをですね
では開けた後にちょっと探してみようかなという気持ちになったと思います
そして周りをこうみた方も何人かいらっしゃったんですけども場合によって青色のあの
人は青色のものを着ているというふうに見つけた方もいらっしゃると思います
実はそこが重要でして
目標を決めることによって今会場内に入ってきたときには
あまり気にしなかった青が
あったんですけども目標を持つことによってそのあを意識するようになったんですね
つまり見えなかったものが見えるようになるっていうのがその目標を決める一番重要な
要素になります
この世の中はもう膨大な情報がありますので私たちの脳はやはりもう不要なものは
どんどんどんどん省いてくれます
でもやはり目標んとなっているものに関し関しましては重要なこともしくは些細なこと
でも
役に立つんじゃないのかということで脳はその情報を収集してくれるんですね
ですので目標を決めるっていうのがまず一番絶対やらなきゃいけないことになります
次がそのと保存勉強してとことん経験をするというものになります
えっ
私たちは目標を決めますそうしますと現場が
比較してその足りないものっていうものが見えてきます
その目標に向かって
足りないもの何が必要なのかというのが出てきます
この時に
ただ見るこれが足りないんだっていうことではなくて
やはりこの不足を解消するためにとことん勉強してとことん経験をしなければならない
です
ちょうどいい例がこのロケットの写真になります
このロケットは地球から月に向かって飛び立とうとしております
その時に膨大なエネルギーを要します
秋冬半端なエネルギーでしたらばもちろん発射することもできまで来ないですしその
目標にたどり着くことができません
私たち人間も一緒です
中途半端には絶対やっていたら目標にたどり着くことはできません
思いっきりやらないとダメなんです私達も思い切りエネルギーを使わないければその
目標に到達することはできません
ではへ
私の
その経験談少しお話ししたいと思います
私にあの目標とする人物がおります
それがこの方本弾直之さんという方です
ご存知の方もいらっしゃるかもしれないです
彼は友人と一緒に
会社を立ち上げて上場して
現在範囲に住んでいます
皆さん憧れのハワイです
そして
彼が目標となってもようになったのには1冊の本がきっかけ
きっかけでした彼が書いた本でして名前がねバレッジ b リングっていう本です
その本の内容は簡単にお伝えしますと
毎日成功したければ毎日一冊本読んで
その学んだことをアウトプットしなさいっていうものでした
私は当時すごく感動しましたので早速それを実際にしました
もうすぐに本を買って毎日一冊本を読むようになりました
その隆がマー当時 koc て少し困っていたことっていうのもありますし
学生時代私ろくに勉強しなかったのでここでちょっと取り返していこうっていう風に
ちょっと思ったんですね
当社その経営のために読んでいた本なんですけれども気がついたらこの方が
私の目標体なっておりました
目標があるということは現状と照れをシェアして何が足りたいのかというのを認識し
ます
それでこれが私です
当時私はすごくハッピーな人だったみたいですね
それでまあ本田さんに近づいていこうあの所になるんだということでいろいろこう悩ん
だんですけれども
彼の著書の中では人生において3つ重要な知識があるということを言っております
そのうちのひとつがそのうちの3つがその永劫 it ファイナンスになります
そしてからあの mea も取得していたんで私も憧れになっていたんで
じゃあも mba もとって
この3つもせも勉強してやろうじゃないかっていうふうに決めました
で問題なのがただそう決めてもしょうがないんで一体どこでそのところと勉強して経験
できるんだというところが重要でした
その答えが私がまあ卒業した学校のハルトインターナショナルビジネススクールという
ところでした
そこは通常2年かかる mba
もしくはファイナンスのプログラムを1年でこうやるんですね
その軽い休みがないんです
つまりもう本当にとことん勉強するしかないという状況になります
私個人はもう本当にあの弱い人なんで
留学に来すぐやられちゃうんですねテレビがあったらもうすぐ僕はあって今見えちゃい
ますし
漫画だったら漫画数読んじゃう人だったんでもうそんな時間を与えない環境っていうの
が私にとって一番重要でした
そこで
ちょうどその眼光はしかもサンフランシスコにキャンパスがありましたので
英語を習得できるということでこの4つのうち mba 5ふぁいのずこの3つが同時
にできてしまうということで早速私は行きました
残り一つ it です
it どうしたらいいんだろうと言った時に
せっかく it メーカーのサンフランシスコに言いますのでここでじゃあ会社をやっ
たらどうだろうということで始めたのがパシャデリックです
asha デリックはあの私のこの不満から始まったサービスです
先ほどお伝えしましたその撮影場所とその情報
これを航行共有するサービスなんですけれども実際
多くの
方々が独占欲もありますので
どこで撮ったっていうのを教えたくないんですね
ところが今この世の中の流れなのでインターネットがあります
もうかなり調べればもう答えが出てくるんです
どうせみんなに公開されて共有されてしまうのであればより簡単に
アクセスできてより素敵な写真が撮れるサービスっていうのを始めたらどうだろうと
いうことで始めたのが
のパシャデリックでした
つまりより多くの方々により多くのステキな写真が撮れるチャンスをこう与える
サービスとしていま
運営しております
ではチャンスはどこからやってくるのでしょうか
それはやはり私は一からやってくるんじゃないかというふうに思っております
とことん勉強して今度はとことん経験をしますおその人自身に自信がつきます
時にあの根拠のない自信とかなんかいう人もいるんですけども
街選び自信がついてきますそしてその地震そのものというのは
第三者から見れば安心があったりもしくは非常に今魅力的だったりするんですね
ですので学生の間でもいち早くこう就職活動ができる方も
もしくは上司からプロジェクトを任せられるかとももうその人自身に自信があるから
なんだ
この人に任せれば安心もしくはこの人に任せればできるっていうふうに思ってくださる
からこそチャンスを与えてくれるって言うものになります
先ほどの mba の続きなんですけれども
実は卒業する時に私に一つのチャンスがやってきました
それは卒業式の時に早大としてスピーチを行うと良いものでした
当時私はちょっとこうショックだったんですけども
5それに私もとことんやりましたので快く引き受けました
このチャンスは実際学校からの評価とそして生徒からの投票によって私の名前が
ノミネートされました
ではどうして彼らは私を選んでくれたのでしょうか
主に3つあります
先ず一つが英語力なんですけども英語力って言ったってあの
ネイティブの一人私しゃべれるよとかそういうわけではないです
そのプロセスの一体私がどこからどこまで英語力伸びてきたのかというところを見て
くれたんだと思います
mba の入学直前まで私現地の英語学校にいたんですけどそれ学校側もクラスメイト
もみんな
しておりました
入学当時あまりまだそこまで喋れなかったのがもう
卒業の的には
チームメートネイティブの人に対して自分の意見がしっかりいえて説得することが
できるというような状況になっていたのが
特に学校側がなかなか小磯いないということで評価してくれました
次がそのプレゼンテーションなんですけれども
私は先ほどそのとことんやらなきゃいけないっていう中でせっかくその留学をしていく
んであれば
を全てやろうっていうふうに決めておりました
ですので通常プレゼンテーションであればやはり恥ずかしいとか
英語がやっぱり甘くないからということであまりやらない方もいるんですけども一切
全てに手を上げて率先して行いました
その結果何が起きたかと言いますとクラスメートからはもう
プレゼンテーションやるんであれば山ぐらいに任せれば大丈夫だと
有用な定評がつきました
最後が授業への貢献度っていいものです
これもまあ英語のその経験をしていくという家の一つだったんですけれどもアメリカで
は日本と違って二軍への貢献度っていうのが成績にすごく影響を与えます
そこで私はもう
これぞとばかりに手を挙げて
自分のその過去の知識と経験をクラスのみんなと言うと先生にこう共有していったん
ですね
その結果
まあ先ほどのその早大のそのスピーチをやらせていただいたというチャンスおこう
もらうことができました
最後になりますけれども私はやはりその人生はもうチャンスと可能性で詰まっていると
いうふうに思っております
そして何事も遅いということは全くありません
マクドナルド兄弟から6店舗を買収して世界的チェーンにもってたこの例63も始めた
時は52歳です
しかも糖尿病を患っておりました
私自身も
アメリカに行こうっていうふうに決めたのは35歳でした
今年で41歳ですでもまだまだたくさんのその大冒険をしていきたいというふうに考え
ております
むしろ中には
いやーそんなチャンスが来ても困ると私そういうのはできません
喪主はそんな責任もてませんという方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
でもそれはただ単に準備がまだ整っていないだけなんです
ちゃんと準備とことん勉強して
経験をしていけば間違いなくそのチャンスが来た時に快く引き受けることができます
チャンスが来た時も c
断ってしまえば
それは100%何かを取り逃がしたということになります
そして船そのものというのは港にいれば安心なんですけれどもやはりそのために作られ
たわけではないんですね
大航海をするという大冒険のためにその船を作られております
どうしてもその恐怖
いうのが先に逝ってしまうようであればやはり今目の前にあることをこつこつとやって
努力をしていけば間違いなくその恐れというのを回避することもできると思います
よって最後なんですけどもやはり具体的な目標を持ってそしてその足りないものを自分
で認識してもうとこと勉強してとことん
経験をしてください
そうすれば勝手に自信が付いつきまして勝手にチャンスというのは人とともに
むこうからやっていきます
私も引き続きほとん
やリスクして
いろんなチャンスを掴んでいきたいと思いますどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]